[Applaudissements]
h
les enseignants coranique au début il
disait que j'ataquis l'islam il a fait
16 ans que j'ai fait ce film il y a 16
ans encore il disait la même
chose j'ai attaqué le business de la
mandicité des enfants c'est ça que j'ai
attaqué j'ai pas attaqué l'islam de
puusque tu peux pas attaquer ma propre
religion alors mais maintenant c'est
c'est c'est c'est disons une une
réaction
corporatiste les réaction CIT réaction
corporatiste qui disait que si tout le
monde pense comme lui nous allons plus
ex on va nous nous allons disparaître et
cetera notre business va disparaître si
notre business disparaît on disparaît
non il faut le faire comprendre non il
faut pas manger ça c'est c'est c'est
c'est pas négociable mais ça va pas dire
que vous allez pas ça va pas dire que
vous allez disparaître non dites-nous
quelles sont les solutions ensemble nous
cherchons une manière que vous puissiez
gagner votre vie à travers votre métier
qui est d'enseigner le Coran un métier
c'est pour pouvoir en vivre donc qu'on
ne dise pas que enseigner le Coran doit
être une activité gratuite au fond ce
n'est pas gratuit dans la mesure où
c'est l'enfant qui
paye je pense que on a beau euh disons
jeté le prob sur les marabous et les
Maes coraniques je crois que il faut en
jeter le double sur
nousmême nous sommes nous nous nous
sommes nous sommes le
carburant c'est nous qui alimentons le
problème mais
aussi lui donner une bougie un sachet de
lait et tout cela ça ça relève plutôt de
ce que j'appelleraai vulgairement la
sorcellerie le charlatanisme a fait
que le
citoyen sénégalais et je sans mentir je
peux dire que tous les citoyens
sénégalais sont responsables parce que
quand ils vont consulter un marabou pour
leur faire l'oracle ils doivent donner
une
charité
h
cette scène j'y tenais parce que tout
simplement c'est un March de
dupe le papa sait bien que le marabouou
ne pourra pas entainir son
enfant et qu'il va le faire manger il le
sait bien il le sait très bien lui aussi
le marabou sait bien aussi que son ce
papa là il lui a donné son enfant pour
s'en débarrasser quelque part chacun
joue maintenant dans le registre
religieux en disant que
Dieu vous a donné la grande capacité de
nous éduquer enfants de manière
religieuse c'est vous qui déz le Coran
on peut pas vous payer même pour ça ce
même discours est enain de tenir à
l'heure actuelle on dit pas la V ça jour
parce que faut pas faire la poli de
l'Autriche tout ce que il le P
toutas je pense que l'État prend souvent
très
mal des fois il Atta par un bout
seulement alors que le problème global
je dis il y a le parent il y a le
marabou il y a l'état et il y a le
citoyen il faut que il y ait une sorte
de disons de commission je sais pas moi
en tout cas un lieu de dialogue
permanent un lieu de dialogue permanent
où tous ces entités sont représenté et
discutent mais de manière disons
réaliste et est
vrai
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai voulu faire ce film du point de vue
de l'enfant en montrant que cet enfant
c'est un être humain c'est pas parce
qu'il est jeune moi je je développe
toujours l'idée que l'enfant naî avec
toute son intelligence à partir de ce
moment j'ai dis ce gosse si je prendre
son Essie dere dans son point de
vue il va développer des choses en
disant que je suis honnête comme toi
j'ai le même droit que toi pourquoi tu
me tu me tortures pourquoi tu me fais
travailler pourquoi j'ai pas droit à de
l'affection de ma maman pourquoi toi en
tant que parent tu prends pas tes
responsabilité à partir de ce moment
aussi j'aien fait un être
contestataire finalement subversif qu'il
apprenne à travers ce film à se prendre
en charge à avir le S
le sens de la digité le sens de la
liberté pas faire des
choses quelqu'un fait des
injus
[Musique]
R mais est-ce
que